what if you could make ten thousand
dollars a month working from home
quitting a job you hate and having
freedom in this episode of the think
media podcast we're gonna be exploring
the opportunity of not just creating
content on YouTube but actually being a
YouTube channel manager for clients and
our special guest today is actually
going to be teaching us about the
opportunity of becoming a freelancer and
really a service-based business but
doing it from the angle of being able to
control your own time and earn a lot of
money doing it she's going to be sharing
the mistakes and some tips for getting
started and this is kind of a
little-known way of basically becoming a
full-time YouTuber even if you're not in
the videos yourself and so Brandy miles
is a service based business owner that
teaches simple strategies for generating
consistent Revenue fast so you can have
more freedom them and be financially
secure for your family and enjoy
guilt-free Target shopping sprees on the
regular one of the reasons I love Brandy
is because she is a family first type
person but also a world-class
entrepreneur helping service-based
business owners and I think the
opportunity for our community is
thinking outside of the box in terms of
this opportunity of being a YouTube
channel manager as well as many other
things websites Etc Facebook ads and so
can you speak to us a little bit about
where'd you come from what you're doing
and the opportunity of being a
freelancer this year yeah so I've never
had like a regular job or a nine to five
job and so I went straight from college
working in restaurants all the time and
then to law school and even from there I
saw this reality that I didn't want to
work 60 hours 70 hours a week and make
six figures like that didn't sound like
Freedom or flexibility to me so I got
into direct sales that was my first
taste of really entrepreneurship and I
spent eight years in there growing a
very successful business in focusing and
marketing and doing things differently
than other direct marketers were doing
it but when I was eight months pregnant
with my daughter I was like this is not
the life I want to live left that behind
had no idea what I was going to do and I
stumbled upon freelancing it was
something that I could be My Own Boss I
could be at home with my daughter she
was five months when I started my
business but what I didn't know is how
big this could grow and the
possibilities I felt like a few extra
thousand dollars a month diapers formula
that kind of stuff never in my wildest
dreams did I think it would turn into
what it did and I think a lot of people
don't realize the true potential and so
I started doing marketing tasks for
people so email marketing Building Sales
funnels and then I went all in on
Facebook and Instagram ads as a marketer
for running ads for people and from
there it just my business blew up
I learned a lot about what was working
what didn't work I brought a lot of
skill for my previous eight years and
I'm running my own business to this and
changed kind of what everyone else was
doing when it came to freelancing and
now we're here four years later I only
work with top dollar one-on-one
Consulting clients now and then I have
two programs where I help Freelancers
really scale their business so they can
have that freedom and flexibility as
well and since then my husband and I we
live in Florida we have we just built
our dream house down here and then I
have a daughter and we have another one
on the way so family is definitely like
one of my top priorities in building my
business around that that's amazing and
I'm curious as we talk about the
opportunity and maybe even
the necessity of creating different
income streams or seeing where the world
is going you know there's so much fear
right now talking about a looming
recession in fact all you're hearing in
the media entrepreneur.com literally
called 2023 the year of fear they like
labeled the year fear which I got my
opinions about just that kind of
messaging I don't find it very helpful
but the truth is you also don't want to
just be Pollyanna and positive you you
want to learn new skills what would you
say in light of you know there's maybe
layoffs or or different job disruption
or maybe people feel capped
what is the opportunity to diversify
your income starting a side hustle or
potentially actually
completely changing your lifestyle in
terms of not just being able to work
from home but earn money what are you
seeing in the opportunity with
freelancing yeah I think we're on the
same page with the fear messaging that's
not my game but I also want people to be
prepared I'm a big proponent of multiple
income streams and people ask me like
what about is this gonna be like 2008
I'm like I have no idea I was like
graduating high school in 2008 but what
I do know is we saw during covid a lot
of people lose their jobs and we saw a
lot of people who maybe they were
working with one type of client and that
client could no longer support them
because their business was shut down and
they were able to Pivot and so one thing
I do know going into 2023 is one of the
best things you can do is invest in
learning a skill and that's not like
making sourdough like a lot of people
are doing in 2020 it's like how can you
learn a tangible skill and what's so
amazing is now you don't have to go get
a college degree to do this you there's
so many resources online and I know that
when you have those skills you're going
to become much more valuable because
what we've already seen is as businesses
do layoffs they they need people to
still work and it's much cheaper to hire
a freelancer a consultant something
that's not an employee to replace those
people and another thing we're saying is
like people just aren't working or at
least it doesn't seem like it everyone's
hiring and there's tons of opportunity
and no one to fill these roles so it's
opened up this amazing hole in the
marketplace for Freelancers and
Consultants to thrive right now and so I
would say the best thing you can do
moving forward is learn a skill that's
going to serve you in your own business
if you want it but also serve in other
people's businesses because people are
still going to be hiring Freelancers and
Consultants no matter what they economy
does because it's better to have them
than employees yeah that's so powerful
and a little bit later on in our
conversation we'll be talking about
maybe how to get started maybe some of
the best skills some mistakes people
make or even how to scale their revenue
um but one of the biggest opportunities
we talked about recently on your show
that I'm seeing is this opportunity to
be a YouTube channel manager and a lot
of people that listen to the think media
podcast is their goal is to be full-time
on YouTube it could be hard to Define
that because we have many entrepreneurs
and business owners that listen and they
just want more leads and sales and so
maybe they're trying to get some other
top type of product or service off the
ground using YouTube as marketing but
then many of our community actually want
to do YouTube full-time but from ad
Revenue as a personal brand as a content
creator and what I oftentimes encourage
people because I'll get Skeptics that
say do you think that everybody can be
successful on YouTube I actually say
yeah I actually do I don't believe
though that everyone's going to be
successful on YouTube by maybe being the
charismatic front person I think that
the opportunity to be successful on
YouTube could look in a lot of different
ways maybe you're on camera and you're
the charismatic front person maybe you
create a faceless Channel where you are
uh using other people's content via fair
use and Creative Commons and
royalty-free content to build up income
that way of course you could work for a
Creator on their staff you could do
video production and all kinds of
different things but this role of
YouTube channel manager of being like a
YouTube producer you know you and me are
in a mastermind together and we've known
each other for a couple years and and I
have found that not 80 not 90 percent a
hundred percent like maybe it's 99.9
besides the one person that is a is kind
of a appear in our business groups want
a YouTube channel manager they're saying
I'm so busy and I can shoot I can turn
on my phone or I can record turn on
stream yard and record a video but man
the thumbnail the title the description
keeping the channel updated maybe
editing the content
um down a little bit or repurposing it
or putting it multiple places that is
the blocker for so many business owners
that have money that want to pay
somebody and so I'm so passionate about
having you come on the podcast because
you help people basically systematize
that and productize that and people in
our community have that skill what skill
do they have they have YouTube and maybe
they haven't been able to get their own
channel off the ground but they
understand titles they understand
thumbnails and I think the opportunity
here as well is maybe you end up being
the graphic designer with canva for the
thumbnails and you be all of these
different pieces but even if you don't
know how to be a graphic designer people
just want to hire the producer you could
then basically subcontract that to
Fiverr to someone else you could have an
account like design pickle where they're
maybe doing multiple designs and you use
that account you got to be the DJ the
producer and so this opportunity in 2023
of being a YouTube channel manager
starting a freelance service based
business there I'm telling you there is
a blue ocean because there's not enough
of them they're not marketing well and
that's where you come in and by the way
if you're in a rush or whatever I want
to make sure you don't miss out on
Brandy's class if you want to learn how
to consistently do 10K months you could
go to thinkbrandy.com and we'll put a
link she has an hour-long class that'll
get you a lot more tactical step-by-step
startup information being a YouTube
channel manager is a massive opportunity
my question for you is where do service
providers break down if that was their
skill but now now they're like I want to
Market it or they're finding like I got
that skill but where do I get clients
what are some of the biggest mistakes
the people you serve make
um in this area yeah and I just want to
talk really quick that there's this
hugeot Gap and I don't know why it is
that no one is marketing themselves as
this channel manager but it's very
similar to being a podcast producer and
we have so many podcast producers and so
with that you're pretty much a project
manager that's doing all the moving
parts and like Sean said you can
Outsource whatever you want and but one
thing we see is if you decide to go down
this route is a few mistakes in the
beginning one you think you have to
charge hourly which is like the worst
thing you can do because it's horrible
experience for the
um client because they just want to know
how much it's going to cost them for you
to manage their YouTube channel and if
that means that you know it's different
every single month that's not great for
their bookkeeping it's not great for
your bookkeeping but just setting
guidelines so having a package instead
of hourly I think is one of the best
things you can do and secondly to that
is stay off upwork and places like
Fiverr and stuff when it comes to you
deciding what your packages are because
what they're doing is different than the
skills you're bringing and so we get one
thing I see is people get in this like
right like oh there's people overseas
that charge five dollars like how could
I ever do that but you're setting
yourself up for a client who doesn't
want the time difference the time zone
difference they want someone who is
closer to them that can get this up
that's part of their team even if you're
a freelancer and so you're gonna price
yourself in a way that makes you
desirable and because you know how much
value you're bringing if you save a
YouTuber 20 hours a month which I don't
know how much time but I would imagine
Sean your team's like it takes a lot of
time to produce even them four videos a
month oh my gosh if you're saving them
20 hours what can that Visionary do what
can they go out and accomplish and so
pricing yourself based on the value you
bring and not by the hour is going to be
really really important for your success
in the business but also creating a
really great experience for the clients
and then when it comes to marketing the
biggest mistake I see people make is
they're just not doing it it's crazy to
me that people think that they can post
on Instagram and have like a flood of
clients and I call that passive
marketing that's marketing where you're
throwing something up crossing your
fingers and hoping it works out kind of
like if you just threw a YouTube video
up without any SEO title thumbnail
anything like that and hoping you start
to get viewers instead what I encourage
my service providers to do is what I
call Active marketing and that's for
most of you if you're working with
YouTubers maybe it's going into Sean's
group not spamming it but looking to
answer questions for people if someone's
like hey I'm like dying over here how
can I get all this done offering some
advice and then making sure your profile
is optimized so if they see what you're
doing they're like oh that's what you do
or I'm sure there's people in there that
are asking like hey I need help with my
Channel How can you help me popping in
there and showing like this is what I do
this is my specialty that's active
marketing not spamming groups active
marketing by providing value instead of
just crossing your fingers and hoping or
reaching out directly to YouTubers that
you think would need your service that's
going to get you a lot more clients than
posting something on Instagram or Tick
Tock and hoping that a client comes your
way and having a goal of how many people
you're going to connect with each week
in my previous career I would come home
every day from law school and make 50
cold calls to Brides like 50 cold calls
let's pay you on the phone calling
people being hung up on and we're so
lucky now we live in a time where we can
send emails or a DM or something like
that and how many of those do you need
to do to get on a call and so the third
and final mistake I see people make is
they just don't have any systems set up
and it creates a really bad experience
from the get-go and so if someone said
is like yes this is what I need how can
I book a call to learn more they're like
oh okay I have this time and this time
available but instead of doing that you
can automate all this through systems
like dubsado or honeybook that's going
to take care of your sales call it's
going to take care of your contracts
your invoices and too many times people
think they don't need that until they
have a lot of clients but the thing is
you'll get a lot more clients if you
start with that right off the get-go
because you want to seem like the
professional not the amateur let's do
the math on doing a 10K month and a huge
unlock that you shared there was you're
right podcast producers is a major
service that is provided there are many
and it's a big opportunity in
freelancing but again back to the
classic book Blue Ocean strategy you
want to look where there's opportunity
and it's perfectly aligned with who
we're talking to because many people
listening to this are already a part of
video ranking academy uh which would be
our proprietary process in in YouTube
optimize and and all of the above and
the YouTube skill set so if you take the
skill of I'm a YouTube channel manager
and you start to do active marketing and
you've got your systems how many what
could the math be on a ten thousand
dollar month maybe compared to what you
know podcast producers are doing yeah so
I think the going the average so there's
gonna be people who charge a lot so
let's see is an average of about two
thousand dollars for full production but
that's for four shows that are under 45
minutes so editing those that's going to
be like putting the show notes up on the
website creating the graphic and
uploading it so uh with podcast
management they're not like posting on
social Forum they may create a graphic
to post on social maybe an audiogram but
it's really like producing it some of
them for an additional fee will schedule
guests and things like that but for most
beginners we're seeing about two
thousand dollars so if you and I think
YouTube channel management would
actually probably be more than that
um based on like just knowing the
different levels and that's the other
thing you have to decide what you're
going to offer and what you're not going
to offer so if you're not offering
graphic design because maybe they
already have someone then maybe yours is
a little more but maybe you're like I'm
fully optimizing this thing then maybe
you're closer to three thousand but
let's just choose this 2000 because it
seems to be the number that gets thrown
around a lot in the podcasting world and
so we're looking at five clients
and that's ten thousand dollars a month
once you get your systems and depending
on how much you're out like getting
Graphics done on Fiverr things like that
then it doesn't mean you're working 40
hours a week by any means to hit those
ten thousand dollar months and then and
and really getting granular give me an
average of you definitely invest in some
tools maybe there's some startup costs
and putting that aside but you've got
the tools the workstation to do the work
you are Outsourcing let's just say an
average amount what do you think net
profit take-home pay because you now are
a small business owner uh you're an
independent contractor a sole proprietor
and so that would be your top line
revenue what do you think bottom line
could be on average just ballpark so
most of our service providers so if
you're doing 10K months it's actually
120 000 a year a lot of people think
that that's a hundred thousand for some
reason but it's not it's 120 000 that's
why I like
um to focus on 10K months because it
gives you this buffer room but so most
of our service providers run it between
80 and 70 profit like if you're lower
than 70
you're probably Outsourcing a lot more
or you're hiring people that maybe are
over like your prices aren't in
alignment with what you should be
Outsourcing so but for most part they
run at 70 to 80 profit that's why it's
like I always say it's the fastest path
to cash online is a freelancer because
you don't have a ton of overhead and
that's pre-taxes so I mean because the
tax brackets are going to change for
everyone so if you're at 120 and then
you are making 70 profit you're taking
home a almost six-figure income yeah I
if you were at the the 80 profit as you
said
you're making ten thousand dollars a
month
you're spending two thousand dollars a
month on Outsourcing a few things in
your software whatever other expenses
you'll end up with ninety six thousand
dollars a year
um and to to your point number one
that's an incredible income number two
you also you you're saying once you get
this thing optimized you're working less
than 40 hours a week and you're working
from home you have more freedom and
flexibility
um and so just better peace of mind more
value of family but on top of that
you've also stepped into this
opportunity of being a small business
owner as Robert Kiyosaki taught us all
in the Rich Dad Poor Dad book years ago
the cash flow quadrant when you're a W-2
income you're taxed not only do the tax
the tax is terrible but you're also
taxed up front as opposed to at the end
of things people go oh I'm getting a
great tax return no you aren't the
government held your money hostage they
kept it for a year and then they gave it
back to you you could have had it the
whole time not only could it have been
working for you but it's above the line
below the line in the sense of you got
96 000 left over but now you got your
write-offs and so you're being smart
with your home office right off you're
being smart with your your vehicle or
your phone or your internet connection
and all these different things and so
it's not even Apples to Apples 96 000
might be already better than the job
you're working right now and you could
be a YouTube channel manager for others
have enjoy everything more but it's it's
almost like exponentially bigger because
if you can start adding on your tax
strategies and all the above and then
you also have much more financial
flexibility and freedom because it can
compound that's the tip of the iceberg
would be five clients two thousand a
month
um you start getting better at team and
systems going deeper into your stuff
it's it's pretty exciting maybe more
clients maybe build out a small team but
one of the cool things you help people
do is do it without a team do it like in
a
um you know in a really cool way so
people can really lean on their values
and that's one of the things that you uh
if you do want more on this Brandy does
have a free class so I highly recommend
checking that out that'll be in the show
notes you can go to think brandy.com but
but speak to that of the the vision that
is kind of like how to scale to
consistent ten thousand dollar months
without hiring a team what are some of
the things you break down on that class
yeah so one of the things is when I came
into the freelance World I'd hit six
thousand dollar a month but I was like
exhausted overwhelmed it was too much
and so I knew if I wanted to go any
further I was gonna have to change
something and the online space pretty
much gave me two options one you can
grow an agency or two you can create a
course at that time I didn't want any
like I didn't want to have a course I
didn't want anything like that I just
wanted to serve people and then the
other one the agency as a mom a wife I
was like I'm already managing like a
house a husband and a baby there's no
way I want to manage people as well and
so that's when I was like how can I do
this and I dropped some clients learned
some new skills implemented a lot of my
business that I learned before and
within my first 10 months of business
I'd already created over a six-figure
year in my very first full year in
business I had done 250 000 as a
solopreneur now some people think I'm
against teams I'm not against teams I
think there's a time and place to hire
um but one of the things you can do do
is that doesn't mean you can't get on to
Fiverr and have someone do your graphics
for you there's very different than
having someone do that and having a team
that you're responsible for you have to
pay each and every single month even if
you're not getting paid and so I created
this class to help people show them that
you don't have to create a course you
don't have to have an agency model you
can scale a freelance business to
consistent 10K plus months and we do
that through like the first thing I said
is really getting strategic on your
packaging and your pricing this is one
of the biggest misses I see in the
freelancing world two systems no one
talks about this it's like let's grab
this free software this free software
and duct tape it all together when
really you can run your entire business
for less than fifty dollars a month and
everything works seamlessly together so
I teach people how to create this really
beautiful streamless process that
excites the client helps you become a
referral machine and automates a lot of
the back end I love systems I think we
be using them more and so I teach our
Freelancers how to do that and then I
always say I have a servant's heart a
marketer's brain so then of course the
third thing we're going to talk about is
like how do you Market your services how
do you stand out in the crowd and the
great thing for channel managers there's
not much of a crowd for y'all but it's
still like how do we Market our business
consistently to land clients and then
once we get them on a call how do we
close them on that call and then the
fourth thing we're going to chat about
is when is the right time to elevate
your brand or your business so maybe in
that four step that's when you decide
like I want to have my own YouTube
channel to bring people into my world
that would be one of the time to do that
or maybe you want to have a website or
something like that but we focus on all
of that after you've already been making
money you have systems set up and people
are already hiring you then we focus on
all the stuff that people usually worry
about in the beginning before they ever
even get started Brandon you put in the
time and you've made the mistakes and
you've gone through the pain so that you
can help other people go further faster
and I know this is all pretty probably
pretty overwhelming so I highly
recommend if you're at all seeing the
opportunity here
um check out Brandy's class
thinkbrandy.com or the links in the show
notes at the end of it too she'll tell
you more about her products and her
programs which I highly recommend it's
actually a deep conviction of mind that
video ranking Academy learning the skill
of YouTube meets freelancing and
learning Brandy's skills that she
teaches through her company is is a
massive opportunity to build 10K months
and Beyond and to really begin to serve
people at a higher level so think Brandy
by the way Brandy is with an i that's
b-r-a-n-d-i.com thinkbrandy.com that'll
get you there and um one of the things
that's fascinating is is is not just
that you could go through Brandy's stuff
of and do a million things there's so
much opportunity you can do websites
podcasts Facebook ads but what's wild
about this channel manager opportunity
is there's new numbers that came out
from Adobe that said 165 million people
joined the Creator economy since 2020.
previous to that signal fire revealed
that there was already 50 million
content creators
so that means there's over 200 million
content creators that are active
and some are just beginning some are in
the middle of their Journey many are
professionals there's 22 000 channels
that have a million subscribers and so
there's big money coming into those
channels the middle class if you will of
content creators that are on camera
building personal brands that are at
this high five six multiple six figure
type of income and needing help this is
a massive market and a lot of people are
overwhelmed you know you're listening to
this you might feel overwhelmed because
you're like I'm trying to run my channel
and whatnot I just think this is an
interest not only an interesting
opportunity the opportunity is off the
charts it's a supply and demand thing no
demand of uh or no supply of YouTube
channel managers and massive demand for
help especially if you can help people
not just save time and get their time
back but if you also can help them scale
by your ability to write good title
tools and make good thumbnails and maybe
provide them some feedback and you know
there's so much
um this is really exciting so Brandi
fine as we land the plane today what are
some ways to to scale this if we just
keep on the same case study
you had mentioned keeping it simple five
clients two thousand dollars but you you
alluded to maybe you have a couple extra
Services maybe you have a couple extra
this or that what are some of those
power-ups
um that you've seen specifically that
maybe you do serve five clients at two
thousand but maybe there's like a whale
client that wants you to do some heavier
lifting what are some of the
opportunities of how that can scale the
numbers with if you will upsells or
different packages that you teach your
community yeah so I think you know going
in and getting retainer clients is is
always the best way to get started
because it creates that consistent
revenue and then you start to get known
in the industry when you're only
providing one service like a YouTube
channel manager and that's when like you
said the big fish start looking at you
and saying like wait who are you using
who and they start talking and then you
start Landing more clients and what I
always teach is referral clients should
be more than what you like your first
client if they're 2 000 and a referral
comes in and you're getting all and
you're almost full they should be 2500
they should be a three thousand dollar
because you should always be raising
your prices as your skill level raises
you're bringing more value like Sean
said maybe you give some strategy behind
it and then strategy people pay more for
than management but then you get really
good at this and one of the things I
love for our service providers to offer
is intensives I always say ad intensives
for added revenue and what that means is
you're sitting down with someone maybe
for you know two hours three hours and
mapping out what their channel strategy
should be maybe you do YouTube channel
audits Forum where you get in the back
end and you're like here's all the
things that I see that can be fixed and
so that's more of a strategy standpoint
than an implementation and so maybe you
book three of those a month and you know
you're charging 5 fifteen hundred
dollars for those and then they have
someone on their team go and Implement
that that's a really great way to work
with people and then also people need to
a lot of people have been burned by
Freelancers service providers or
employees and so they're not as trusting
so maybe they're not ready to hand you
over two thousand three thousand dollars
for a monthly retainer but they'll do
this one intensive with you and they
fall in love with you find out how much
work it is they're gonna already have
that know like and trust and they're
going to be more apt to hire you the
other way that you can do this is also
by one we talked about adding you're
raising your prices as you go that added
intensives and then bringing on
just people to take off some things
because after you get to 10K months if
you want to continue to add clients you
may not be able to have more than five
retainer clients but you could bring in
other people so maybe you have people
that are just as subcontractors to do
the thumbnails or maybe bring in an
editor that's what our podcast managers
usually do that's the first person they
bring on is someone just to edit for
them so then that takes off a massive
one but the thing with that is you have
to make sure your prices are priced well
enough in order for you to still take
home what you want because now you have
these other people so there's several
ways that you can do this and then of
course affiliate marketing is huge as
someone who is coming in and saying like
hey I think we should use two buddy
tubebuddy or bid IQ you should have
affiliate links for these to be like
giving them and they should be going
through yours or maybe they want to go
live and use stream yard you should be
able to be throwing those to them and
making affiliate on the back end and
then the last way you could do it is I'm
sure when people it's the same thing
with podcast management people want to
launch their YouTube channel and I don't
know if most people only start with one
but I know with podcast management you
start with four episodes when you launch
a podcast so you could only work with
those clients for four weeks six weeks
to launch their YouTube channel and then
they find out how much work it is and
then they're like okay I need you on
going but you have different packages
based on how long they want to work with
you what they think they need and
there's so many cool ways that you can
structure this man that's beautiful a
lot of wisdom there you truly are the
service provider Sherpa the freelancer
Phenom The Client Services Queen and I'm
super grateful for all of that and
obviously it opens up a million
questions and Logistics of setting it
all up and that's your expertise and
that's why people should definitely
follow you and check out that class
we'll link all that up in the show notes
but for people who do want to connect
with you where can they connect with you
on social media Brandy yeah I'm I'm
Brandi miles everywhere
Super Active in my DMs and you're always
getting me in there so I love to make
connections and meet you so if you have
any questions pop in there on Instagram
let me know and I'll be sure to respond
and then of course we have the surf
scale sword podcast I always forget
about my podcast I'm like wait I have
one of those
um that's the best way to learn more
about freelancing for free yeah so check
out all of the above and Brandi thanks
so much for coming on the show thanks so
much
foreign